all right
let's get started hello guys
how are you i hope you are enjoying the
conference
so far and uh yeah that even though
uh we are doing it remotely in this way
it's online it's not the same thing as a
staying together but at least we're
staying safe and uh yeah we still have
the chance to learn
uh something my name is uh marco thanks
for
joining me uh for the next hour um
i'm a developer technologies mvp when i
was first awarded
11 years ago it was uh on asp.net and
iis now it has been rebranded in this
way which is very
fast as a um as an expertise as a topic
but i'm still
very focused on anything that's related
to web and cloud
and today i'm incredibly excited it's my
first time at ndc and i'm incredibly
excited
to talk about my two favorite topics
uh one is a security identity management
in web applications and the other one is
a blazer which
is probably i hope you agree with me but
it's probably one of the coolest
technologies microsoft is working on at
the moment so yeah
really exciting things to discuss for
the next
uh yeah 60 minutes so what are we going
to talk about today
um first of all i uh
i'd like to give you a glimpse of the
object model that we have
available in blazer to deal with
security matters
and then we will see how the security
aspects
so the identity management of our users
is a works slightly differently
depending on whether we are in blazer
server on blazer web assembly
works slightly differently under the
hood because from the programmatic
programmatical perspective what we're
going to use are pretty much the same
classes which is cool
um then once we've successfully
authenticated our users so we're going
to move on
and start having some
including some authorization rules based
on roles and then we will see
a way to do a better modeling of uh
authorization uh than what we can
achieve
with roles and then depending on time uh
i might
i also have some other goodies to show
you like how to deal with security for
progressive web apps or with signalr
um so we will see if we can fit it in
this hour or otherwise feel free to
reach me on slack if you're interested
and i'm i'll be pretty happy to jump on
a call perhaps and
and show you that cool so
without further ado oh just one last
thing uh i've tried we
since the blazer is still a bit unknown
in uh in the landscape so
there's there's a sometimes that you
feel you talk to people who i have very
limited experience with it i tried to
keep
the talk uh starting from the basics
but i've also i'm also dealing with some
more advanced
concepts so hopefully regardless to your
level of experience you will be able
to take away something out of this talk
or at least i hope so
cool so let's start with having a look
at the object model and there are
three main classes i want you guys to
focus on for the next five minutes
right and because these are the classes
that we're going to use throughout
pretty much the entire talk right so
it's very important that you we keep
them in mind
the first one is authorized view
authorized view is a component we can
put it on our pages
and the nice thing about it is that it
basically
allows me to define a couple of uh
different
templates depending on which where
we're going to show to the user
depending on whether he's authenticated
or not
right um actually there are three
templates here
uh available in uh in the authorized
view the third one
is called authorizing and this is
because usually in the context of a
single page web applications the
authorization the authentication process
is an asynchronous
operation so it might be that for a few
seconds we
might want to display a slightly
different template okay
in this case uh authorized or not
authorized means authenticated because i
haven't
specified anything but in this point
here i can specify what what authorized
uh means and we will have a look at that
later on during the talk but this is the
first class
or the other the other important thing
that it gives me is this
context object which is basically
an entry point towards the claims
principle of the application so thanks
to that i can access the current
principle
i can see the claims identity i can look
at the claims
and all the typical things that we do
with claims principles in uh
net applications
the there's a slightly
different implementation of the
authorized view called the authorizer
root view and this is a kind of a mix
between a concept of the authorized view
and the root view that we use for
routing
so what does it mean it means that if i
try to access a url for which i'm not
authorized
uh i can decide what is uh the template
that um i'm going to see right as a user
and what does it mean i'm authorized or
not to authorize the world basically
i think that if you guys are like me and
they've been working with
asp.net uh for a while uh you know what
this authorized attribute
uh means uh in this case again i'm
authenticated or not
or it could be that i can i specify
roles or policies or things like that
all right um
the important bit that uh
we don't have to we we have to focus on
on this thing
is uh that this authorized attribute
only works
in the context of routing you know that
in blazer you can you create components
and components can be either displayed
as a pages as
pages uh when we specify this page
directive
or can be embedded in other pages or in
other components just by using their
markup
right so in this second case if we embed
them
this thing will not work so it's a very
common mistake and
it's important that we um
we keep it in mind so author the
authorized attribute only works in the
context of rooting when associated to an
authorized root view
right the third class that
we need to get acquainted with is
the authentication state provider right
and this is a class that we were never
pretty much never going to use directly
okay but it's the foundation of the two
objects that we've seen before
as you can see it's an absolute class
it's a very simple classes but it
basically exposes just this
method here get authentication status
inc which
gives me access to the uh current
principle
and as you can see it's an abstract
class so
this means that it will have as we will
see very different implementations
depending on which
flavor of laser we're using whether we
are in blazer server or blazer
blazer web assembly but the good thing
is that
the other two components that we've seen
so far they
only rely on the abstract implementation
so
it means that if we create components
libraries and things like that
they will work regardless to the type of
blazer that we're using okay
thanks to this architectural approach
right
so let's start by having a look at how
authentication works in blazer and the
idea here is that i'm gonna show you
some uh flows in the in the slides and
then we're gonna head to visual studio
and see it in action
so play the server in blazer server we
know that
oh and i'll be very quick here because i
think that laser web assembly is
the most intriguing part of blazer but
let's let's talk about this for sake of
completeness so in blazer server we have
our application which is running on the
browser
and the blazer engine is what is running
on the server and the two are connected
with the azure signalr
now what happens is that if for any
reason i have a
an asp.net uh authentication cookie
stored in my browser um signalr and
this again is a built-in functionality
in signalr
will just pass that would just retrieve
the authentication cookie and use it to
create
the claims principle in the hub that
the browser is connected to and
this is basically what allows you to
access your hub context
in the hubs that you create and see that
there's a user property there which is
the current logged in user the kind of
connected user
now blazer makes no exceptions
uh it's just running over a particular
hub called component hub
so how does the implementation of the
authentication state provider
um you remember the class that we we
just saw in the previous slide
look like in blazer server well it's a
it's a pretty simple implementation it's
called the server authentication state
provider and
all the only thing that we need is uh
making sure that we can retrieve this
so the component hub needs to retrieve
this its current claims principle and
set it in the um in that in the instance
of the current scope of the server
authentication state provider and that's
it
so it's a very simple implementation it
just exposes a set authentication state
method
and that's how basically blazer server
um is capable of retrieving the
the current um claim the current
principle of the
uh of the application
so this means that if we look at
which providers we can support in blazer
server well we definitely support the
things that such as a asp.net core
identity or
azure active directory both the
enterprise or b2c
just because uh they work with asp.net
core again the place of server is just
leveraging an existing feature
which already is there for asp.net core
and signal r so basically anything that
works with the xbox core
will work with the place of server cube
so have let's have a look at uh
uh how this works so let's jump to
visual studio and
now the interesting bit is that i just
uh uh
came to know a couple of days ago that
in the webex if i do ctrl shift b
to compile my application it will show a
whiteboard
uh and disconnect my sharing screen so
i'll try to
uh avoid that uh but i'll do my best
but don't play me if it happens cool so
we have this as server
individual application this is basically
just the normal template of uh
uh that you can create from uh from
visual studio
um if i do control f5 and i launch it
uh what visual studio comprise it um i
go there
and if i try to access my counter page
i see this message saying that i'm sorry
but you
may not see this page and this is
because like we were seeing on the slide
in my counter page here i have my
authorized attribute and
in my update tracer where where i've
defined my routing
i have something like this right so this
is the message to show
when the user is not organized however
if i
just add a counter here right
and i relaunch the application i will
see the counter so
this is the important bit i wanted you
to be aware of the authorized attribute
only works when uh we are dealing with
routing
okay cool now let's log in here
and as you can see the moment i hit the
login button what happens is that i've
left
the blazer application and now i'm in
the
normal asp.net core
identity page where i perform the login
and the moment i hit log in
i just get redirected back to the
uh to the page where the placer
application sits and now i can finally
access the counter i see that here i
also get a greeting message
and this is because uh if we go and have
a look at the
login display component this is the
component that goes on the top right
corner of the
main layout as you can see there's a
this authorized view
that can differentiate between when i'm
authenticated or not and
when i'm authenticated it's uh it shows
me a greeting message
otherwise i have a couple of links and
again these are the asp.net core
uh spot and mdc basically identity
links to the login or register pages
okay if we go and have a look at the
dot cs file what we get is uh
other than obviously the uh registration
of
uh asp.net identity i see this uh trad
scope the authentication state provider
which
is the absolute class um
that points to this bizarre named sadly
named
class revalidating identity identity of
navigation state provider or blah blah
blah
but if i go and have a look at the
hierarchy of uh of inheritance
as you can see this ultimately inherits
from
uh hopefully you can i can get to the
definition of this
uh inherits from the server
authentication state provider that we
mentioned on the slides
and this is the class that exposes the
set authentication state
thanks to which the component hub can
set the current principle for
for this instance of uh of the
application
all right uh the reason why we're not
using this directly but we're using that
this class here is simply because
uh we want to support the remote sign
out
uh capability that we have in sp core by
uh checking that the security stamp of
the of the user is
still valid but apart from that the
principle
uh the principle by it by uh by which it
works is exactly the one that i've
described you on slides
okay so uh i would say that this could
be enough for blazer server again the
cool stuff is
in a laser web assembly so let's uh go
ahead with that because uh uh
it's probably more interesting okay so
how
all of this is different in blazer web
assembly so in blazer web assembly as
you know we have
our c-sharp application running on the
browser and interacting
with the dom so per se
this application is obviously not
capable of managing users all right
i needed to rely on an external identity
provider which could be
either the hosting application azure
active directory or for example could be
identity server 4 which is a what we're
going to use
during during this talk and uh
how does a blazer interact with identity
server do we have some
strange c sharp code not at all we are
using
idsclient.js it's a piece of javascript
but which is uh referenced
by by the portal and it's basically the
uh
probably the most commonly used uh
javascript client
for uh uh for open at the open id
connect protocol
right so it's not made by microsoft it's
it's pretty much an industry standard
and uh so this is why how blazer
interacts with uh with the identity
provider
under the hood uh again we need an
implementation of the authentication
state provider class
and this implementation is called the
remote authentication service
and the way this works is a
very very very again simple uh it's just
uh so let's pretend that i've already
authenticated the user
via odc client in some way we'll see how
in a second
so there is a a token being passed by
uh is4 to my browser and stored in the
local in the session storage
uh by this client the only thing that
the
remote authentication service does is
using js interop
to retrieve this user uh from uh from
javascript
and uh create a claims principle within
the application
right um so this is really it it's as
simple as that
and uh how do we trigger the uh the
authentication
process or perhaps the sign out where
it's done through
another interface implemented by the
same
object okay so remote authentication
service also implements i remote
authentication service
which exposes the two methods sign in
and send out and these methods will just
trigger again the justice raptors around
the logic which is a
uh within the oic client right they will
just trigger the
uh the function uh in javascript
however we're pretty much never gonna
use these
uh methods directly because uh
the default template comes with uh this
page here called uh authentication which
internally
uses this object to call remote
authenticator view and what is that
so this is an object that wraps up the
logic around
all the flows that happened during an um
open id connect interaction between the
client
and the identity provider and without
going into much detail uh the concept is
that it exposes this action property
we call it with the flow that we want to
trigger so for example action equals
login
and this will uh trigger all the
entire thing for me same for profile or
even the callbacks
that we might receive from the uh from
the identity provider so there's a login
called backhand
chain for example cool
which providers are supported in blazer
web assembly well we have a
obviously uh identity server azure
active directory and
active directory b2c uh the first two
are
available directly from visual studio
for everyone we need to
uh still use the net cli but basically
anything that will that
works with the uh odc client so
implements openly connect and all who
can make uh we can make it work with a
blazer web assembly sometimes
uh i've from my experience we need some
tweaking
but but you can can potentially work
cool let's have a look at all of this uh
in visual studio left so let's go back
here
in the solution let me close these files
and
as you can see i have this blazer web
assembly
um folder in which the first project is
a
identity server for and in identity
server for
the configuration for the security
aspect so
which clients authorize is usually
either in a configuration file or
in a c-sharp file like this one right so
if i go and have a look at this c-sharp
file
what i have here is a this client called
the blazer that i have configured
in which i specified a few things so
first of all it's a single page
application so i'm using
a client type code this is the type of
work of a workflow that we're gonna
implement
uh with a uh open id connect it supports
the
proof keycode exchanges security
protocol and the other important thing
that i'm specifying here are these
scopes that this laser application
is required allowed to request
and what are the scopes a scope is
basically a think about it as a set of
claims
a predefined set of claims that blazer
can uh can request and then receive
so here i have open id and profile uh
these scopes are defined here in this
section i can potentially add another
one
like i don't know there are there are a
few predefined here in
uh in is4 for example email
and i can say that yeah blazer can
request also this
email scope right plus a further a
bunch of other parameters like the
course configuration redirect uris etc
cool um if we go to blazer web assembly
uh so i have this application here let's
have a look
at what i get out of it uh
so um if i click on program
uh this is pretty much the default
template that you
obtained when you decided to go and
add the new project to your solution you
select
a blazer application and
uh here in this page you you say that
you want
individual user accounts so all that you
get is a very generic configuration
um that starts with that basically only
has this odd
ad or ibc uh authentication uh extension
method
and then you have to provide the
configuration uh you can provide it
either by code or in a configuration
file in this example is by code
simply because it's more clear for for
our scopes but
but then we will see later how to
configure it by um
app settings so what do i have here i
have basically the counterpart of
all the things that i've set in in is4
so i have that the client it is called
blazer
uh the type of flow is going to be code
if i want to um the this the two scopes
open id and profile are already
predefined
in in as default parameters but i can
add some additional scopes for so for
example the email one
that we've added before and that's
uh pretty much really really it so let's
start these two projects so let's begin
by starting
the identity provider project
all right so this is is4 running and now
let's go to the laser application
controller 5 not ctrl shift b
and let's run this right
so how does it work uh here i've also
set my uh counter page beyond behind the
um uh authorizer uh attributes so if i
click
counter i get redirected as you can see
to uh identity server four
um just by a chance how did i do that um
well if i go to the pages and look at
the counter
i have my authorized attribute what
happens to be here in the routing this
time is a redirect
to login component this is a component
uh which is here in the application
and it just navigates to the uh
authentication
login endpoint okay this is the page
that uses this
uh remote authenticator view uh thing
that we've seen
on the slides and so this allows me to
login
i can log in as a bob for example
and here uh i get my consent screen i
can send it to these flames and now
i'm back to the application i can
successfully
access my um my page
if i log out i can re-login
as a as alice uh the other user default
user that i have here and everything
will pretty much work
exactly exactly in the same way
cool so this is uh the very basic thing
that we managed to do
and it's really not that useful
unless we are capable of calling an api
right so this is uh going to be our next
task so how do we call uh an api what do
we need to do
well what do we need to do is basically
uh requesting an access token
for for the api for this protected api
and in order to do that
we have this third interface implemented
by the remote authentication service
called i access token provider this
provides
a request access token method uh when i
call it it
again just a javascript interrupt
interrupt it calls a odc client which
will request
an access token to the identity uh to an
entity server
what's an access token an access token
is a pretty much similar to the id token
we've seen before
the only difference being that it's not
meant to be consumed by
my application here it's meant to be
just a
considered opaque by this application
and uh forward it
to um the api we want to the resource
that we want to consume
this access token contains the identity
of the user which means that
in the web api i will be able to uh
access the claims principle uh of uh
of the http context right so it's
basically like blazer
was impersonating the logged in user uh
when
making this call to the web api all
right so we need to request the access
token and embed it uh
in the subsequent request by the uh as a
better token in the authorization header
the good thing is that we don't have to
do it uh manually okay blazer has a
some automatic thing uh components that
uh
does it for us and it's called the
authorization message
handler uh it's basically a component
that gets embedded
in the http client pipeline and
can automatically retrieve this access
token for us either
in the local cache or by querying
is4 and add it as a as a
better token in the authorization header
when making the request to the
to the weather api and we will see that
in action in a second all right
cool let's see how oh how all this works
i need to close
these two uh running applications and
let's go back to visual studio
and so what do we need to first of all
let's go back to
my identity provider and
here what i have is a i've defined an
api resource right so this is my web api
that i want to be able to call
i gave it a name and i said that um
when uh someone asks for an access token
for this api
these are the claims that need to be
added
to this api right so this is just
another scope that we can request to
blazer
uh provided that these are it's among
the uh
allowed scopes that we have now here in
is4 okay
but apart from that uh it's just a this
is
these are the only changes that we need
to do in um in identity server
and then i have a weather api project
and in my weather api project in the
startup i've configured
that i want to use the jotbetter
authentication scheme
and here i'm saying that uh yeah this is
the authority
uh which is going to issue those tokens
i expect an audience on that token
called the weather api
and then i've also specified the uh
claim
uh type that is going to represent my
name
that's it for the configuration it's
just the default standard configuration
for oauth to in in web api
uh the other thing that i've done is
that here in the
weather forecast controller i put my
authorized attribute so that only
authenticated user will be able to
call this controller and to show that i
get the identity of the user back from
is4 as part of that token i'm also
returning the
the name of the user as part of the
response right so pretty standard stuff
let's have a look at blazer and
if you played with it you know that you
call uh there's a this default page
called the fetch data that i will call
this api uh
since the api is protected i felt that
it was a good to protect
also this page with the authorized
attribute i'm injecting
an http client and all i do to populate
this page is making this call here in
which i'm just
getting i'm just calling the the get
endpoint that i'm supposed exposing here
right so i'm not dealing with
any type of authentication whatsoever
in this particular page everything will
be configured
in the program.cs file so what do we
need to do here
well first of all we need to say that we
want to request
also the weather api scope
as part of the
as part of the default scopes that uh
their api as part of the default scopes
and then i needed to configure the http
client that i'm going to use
in my fetch data right i need to make
sure that i can inject an http client
in this page how do i do that uh well uh
there's a
i can register and uh via hdr in fact i
http client factory uh this weather api
client naming client whose base address
is this one
and then the idea is that i'm going to
register also as a single tone this is
pretty much the equivalent thing of the
same
yeah listening here um so every time
uh someone asks for an http client i
just return
the client from weather api that's
really it
and then the last bit is configuring
this client
to uh in order to request automatically
this access token when
uh when when invoked and
we can do that by this add the http
message handler method
and here we're configuring this
authorization message handler
and what we're saying is basically that
every time
we hit a an end point uh whose domain
is a localhost 5002 which is my api
localhost
this is this message handler needs to
make sure that there's a weather api
access token embedded in the request
right
cool let's hope that everything works
and see it in action
so let me just switch to
multiple startup projects and i can
finally do a control f5 and launch this
right so is4 has started the api has
started and
as you can see it's returning me a 401
because i'm not authorized
to access this endpoint just by get i
need to
include obviously an access token to it
let me close a few tabs here
um and if i go to blazer and i hit the
login button let's
log in this time with that as alice
i hit login and i get asked
for the consent over my weather api
scope as well i hit yes
and let's have a look at what happens
uh during the call so if i go to fetch
data
effectively can get the data back as you
can see
uh the api was capable of recognizing uh
alice smith and
if we look at the at the request here at
the bottom as you can see there's this
better token which has been
automatically added to the header of
that request
and the content of this better token is
something we're gonna easily explore
with a
website like jot.ms and as you can see
is uh
alice smith for an audience of weather
api so that's why
why the api is recognizing it and it's
issued by our identity server and it has
a scope of weather behind
it right cool so
we've already achieved a lot uh
in 35 minutes but we can do more and uh
so let's go back to these slides one sec
because um
obviously being able to call an api it's
interesting
uh especially a secure api
but any uh real world application will
need
something more than that and more
specifically we need
to be able to differentiate between
users
so we want to assign some user we want
to define roles assign some users to
some roles and restrict some part of
the application to only those people
belonging to those roles
right so what are roles in a
system like the one we have set up here
well they have a slightly different
meaning depending on the standpoint we
are looking at them
from so for example from the point of
view of
the identity provider identity server
um a role is just like any other claim
okay so it's just a claim that we need
to configure to be added
to the either the id token or the access
token so that it can be consumed by the
client application
all right from the point of view of the
application
it's a a very special type of claim
because we have
some specific logic attached around it
right and um
in the specifics here what happens is
that we want to
make sure that these roles are
recognized by the the framework so that
i can say
authorize all admin and there's a
there's a lot of work that is done
automatically for me uh to check for
that claim to be present
in in the claims principle and allow or
prevent access to a given resource and
this is going to be
pretty much the same both for the client
application
for for the blazer application or the
web api application
right cool so let's have a look
at uh how we can implement this and
in order to do that i need to do a
couple of things so first of all i need
to close these running applications here
uh let's go back to visual studio and i
need to switch to a different branch
um so let me go to changes here
let's comment this and go to branches
and let's go to
roles here all right
so again let's have a look at what we
need to do
in the three components of a of our
solution here
and start with the with identity server
well if we look at the startup in
identity server we are
basically using asp.net identity under
the hood
and the sportsman's identity already
contains a logic to fetch um some roles
from the
uh from the database uh if uh if these
roles are present
and it turns out that um in the demo
database that i have here
let me just retrieve this
open the database here and
if we run this query as you can see i've
already added alice to the user role
and bob to the admin and user role
right so
especially identity will already fetch
these roles for me
but all i need to do then at this point
is a configuring
is4 in order to return them as part of
the uh
two types of types of tokens that we can
release the
id token and the access token how do we
do that well
we need to configure them as a as a
resource uh
here in uh in this
particular property here and we have a
couple of options
either we can define a specific bespoke
identity resource for the roles the
entity resource is basically just a name
a name for the scope and a set of claims
that we want to
add to it or probably better
let's just modify this identity
resources
profile this predefined set of claims
that we associated to the profile
to include also these this role claim so
that we don't have to request a specific
scope to in order to get the roles from
the client so what i've done
is just uh creating this class called
the
profile with the role identity resource
this class is basically just
inheriting from from the default
uh identity resources profile and i'm
adding
the role scope to it right
a very similar thing is what i've done
here in the this api results i've just
added
that i want the role claim to be added
to it as well
and then for uh the find configuration
it's absolutely the same thing i don't
have to touch anything else
let's go to the weather api and here in
the weather api
again no changes in the configuration
whatsoever
nothing to do here the only thing i've
done is that in my
weather controller i'm now restricting
the capability of calling this endpoint
only to uh bob bestly only to those
those users who belong to the admin uh
to the admin role
right what do we need to do in blazer
instead
well let's have a look so first of all
well
in the counter page i've said that a
user can access the counter page
and uh um same goes for the
that's the data page uh here i'm saying
that only admins can add it
there's no point uh there's no reason
for a for normal user to access this
page
because they want to be able to call uh
to call the api
uh what about the configuration well all
i need to do is
specifying that i want to use
the claim type role as the role claim
and that's really it i don't have to do
really anything else
so let's see if all of this works so
let's do controller 5
and launch the application
so i'm now not authenticated i log in as
alice alice if you remember is a user
just a user is not an admin if i say yes
i can go to the counter page now
perfectly works um if i go to fetch data
i see
sorry you're not authorized oh and by
the way this is interesting
uh i slightly changed the routing as
well
because uh obviously
if i'm not authorized and i just
blindly redirected the user to the login
i would have been stuck
in an endless redirect loop here right
so i
check if the user is authenticated only
if it's not authenticated
i redirect him to the login otherwise i
just display this mess this message
saying that you're not authorized to
access the resource
cool uh okay fine seems to be working
let me log out and log in as bob and see
what happens with bob
so i have this user here if login
yes go to fetch data done
you're not authorized and i'm not even
authorized to
access the counter page what the heck is
going on here
so let's look at the claims this is a
claims page that i've set up and
as you can see it seems to be uh
everything seems to be okay so i have my
two roles user and admin
as as bob smith here and they are coming
from
as i said from the object that sits uh
here in ydc client so this is the
counterpart of the claims principle that
sits in this client and as you can see i
have my
array of roles here right user and admin
so
everything seems to be working correctly
why is blazer not recognizing it well it
turns out that unfortunately there's a
bizarre behavior that blazer has when
a claim is an array like what we have
here
it is basically just grabbing the string
representation of the array and it's
creating a uh a
corresponding claim role claim in the uh
claims principle object with that string
representation and this obviously
doesn't work with the authorized
attributes that i put here and there
right so we need to basically in order
for this to work we need to modify
the component of blazer that transforms
the user
that exists exists in the odc client
into the claims principle and
the way we do it is uh by
adding a custom account claims
principle factory so this is the the
object
that performs the transformation between
the java javascript word
and dot network and i have created a
an implementation of it called the array
claims principle factory
all the remote user ops remote user
account
and if we go and have a look at this
class here
um it's relatively simple so it just
inherits from the
default account claims principle factory
right
and overrides this create user sync by
calling the base implementation right so
uh
what i get out of this of this call is
basically
a flames principle hope you can see it
but then what i do is that i iterate
over the
over this dictionary over all the
properties
of the object in javascript and
for each of them i check whether the
object is a either
let's see let's remove this it's i it's
a
a json element and it's an array and in
case it is uh
like for example for the role claim i
remove this role claim
and i add two separate claims
one for each value right so in a
nutshell it's
perhaps easier to watch it in action
than just explaining it if i launch this
again
and i login again as
bob bob smith
what happens is that now my claims are
like this
right and this is a what allows the
authorized attribute
to work uh correctly and also the um
the call to the weather api service okay
so uh it all works pretty much
seamlessly
uh we needed to just a tweak a little
bit the way this uh um
json object it gets deserialized into a
claims principle
otherwise it's pretty it it's pretty
simple
cool let's go back
to the slides because there's a one
thing i
really don't like about roles so i i
tend to avoid using roles as my
as the way i uh
model the authorization from a form for
my application because
there are some some drawbacks if you do
that
well first of all uh as you as you know
if you've done it
uh already well it's very easy to get
your roles as uh end up scattered
across the entire the entire code base
so if you have a
a web an api for example with a hundred
different endpoints you're most likely
gonna have a hundred
authorized attribute with role equals to
admini overall
equals to uh user and uh
if i ask you okay what will can you give
me the list over the end points uh
that a user can call or an admin can
call the only way you can do it
is going through your entire code base
there's no holistic view of what a user
can do depending on its role and this is
annoying
the consequence of this is that
refactoring permissions
is incredibly hard the moment i ask you
to add
a super user which role which sits kind
of in the middle between a user and an
admin
good luck with that you probably will
need to change
dozens of files right simply because uh
again you have these roles
scattered uh everywhere and
this always leads to inconsistencies
like
i don't know for example end points that
can be called by users but not by admins
that's bizarre
but i bet that it has happened to
any of you pretty much once unless so
yeah it's just annoying the other thing
is that usually
you want also the front end to react to
the roles that a user belongs to
in order to perhaps hide or display some
parts of the application
enable or disable some buttons and
it's not easy to do that i mean the the
only thing that you can do is
duplicating the logic
uh on the front-end side pretty much
like we did in the simple example
two minutes ago right so the first data
endpoint can only be called
by admins so there's an authorized admin
uh put on
on the back inside and need to put
another authorized ad pin
on front-end side doesn't there's no
other way to do that
right so can we do better than this i
think we can
uh because well it would be difficult to
do to do any worse than that
and uh i've just released a package
in um in nuget that uh simplifies
this task right it's called the
desk.asp.net core permissions it's still
in a very
uh rough state because i i literally
rushed
it to the nougat gallery uh before this
talk
uh but uh you can also download the
source code uh
in my github account and um
yeah i've used it in production in a
number of different
uh real world applications so it kind of
uh it works and it's inspired by a
policy server which is a commercial
product made by the same company
responsible over identity server
um there's a in this github link
there's a kind of a proof of concept of
a local version of policy server
i think that my implementation is even
lighter but yeah it does it
it does its job uh how does it work
well first of all we start from a
centralized
place where we can describe our
functional permissions and this could be
either my app settings file or my
separate file
right in which i have my permissions
sections and i define things
such as for example can let passengers
board
an airplane and you can only do it if
you are either the captain the first
officer or a cabin crew member
or oh sorry there's a spelling mistake
here and you can fly an airplane
uh obviously you need to be either a
captain or first officer as a role and
you can also add additional
uh claims to this permission here for
example blood alcohol level equals to
zero
or in the case of uh our examples i can
just say
can see forecasts are all equal to admin
all right something like that
now the library will automatically
create policies out of this
configuration
so that i can just say that the
get endpoint for weather forecast is
going to be authorized only to
people who can see a forecast and the
same goes up to the
uh to the front-end side so that uh
either in blazer and in or in the api
i just refer to the abstract permission
i have here and the moment i need to
refactor that permission
i i do it in a centralized place all
right i don't have to
uh modify different files or different
locations on my source code both in the
front end
and in the back end for example uh the
other good thing is that
the module also exposes a slash my
permissions
endpoint you call it with an access
token
and it will return the permissions that
uh that user is entitled to
uh and you can use those permissions to
hide or show
uh pieces of the user interface
right so let's see this in action
uh cool so let's go back to the uh to
the solution here
and as usually i mean as usual i need to
um close all the
running instances here and
move to a different branch
so in explorer
changes and let me reject those changes
here
reject those changes and let's go to
this
permissions branch okay so
what do we have here let's start with
the as usual with the identity server
and if i go to my config page here i
don't have any changes whatsoever
compared to
what we had before and this is because
rules are an
application kind of concept so is4 just
will return me uh sorry permissions are
an application kind of
concept uh is4 will just return me
my roles and that's it right and i will
be responsible of mapping them to my
abstract permissions my functional
permissions so no changes whatsoever on
s4 if i go to my weather api
what i've done here is that in my well
first of all i got that this
permissions dot json file right
where i have nc forecast can use counter
right
mapped it to uh the relevant rules and
uh
i've added it as a separate file i could
have embedded it to the upsettings.json
the way
i did it it's just adding this
additional configuration file
right again you can just use one single
file i just prefer to have it separately
um and then in my startup
class what i've done is just adding
calling this method
add permission policies which comes from
from that unit package
and since we also have a middleware i've
also added
this my permissions middleware that's
really
it and thanks to that i can now go in my
forecast controller and say that this
action is perhaps
only allowed to those who can see a
forecast right
and if we look at the
overload that i'm using yeah this is
using
uh the policy overload right so i'm uh
the module will automatically create the
relevant policies for me based on
on that file cool
let's go and have a look at the blazer
what happens in blazer
so first of all if i go to my
counter page i have a authorized
can use counter and same goes for to my
patch data page right authorize can see
forecast right so i'm
reusing the same permissions that i have
in the back end also
in the front end and the nice thing that
i can do thanks to that
is that um i can now go to for example
my menu
page my menu component so the the thing
that displays
all my links on the left hand side of
the page
and here as you can see i'm i've added a
couple of
authorized views here and here that will
just
that will add the
um links
to those menus only if the person is
has the right permission right so
again i i hope you appreciate it that
there's no duplication of
authorization logic here i just define
what
uh those those permissions as a
combination of claims
these are issued and managed by the
back-end api
and i just use these names these
permission names
as a the authorization policies for
various parts of my
ui right what do i need to do
also in blazer for this for this entire
thing to work
well i need to first of all
um add a custom
authorization policy provider this is
basically what blazer
uses when it sees something like this
policy can use counter okay how how is
it can use counter defined
and this is basically done by this
implementation here permission policy
provider and
if we look at this implementation what i
have
here is uh that i just look for a
specific claim a special claim called
permission
in my claims principle okay i'm just
returning
so give me the policy name can use
counter i just return
an authorization policy builder which is
satisfied only when
i have a permission called uh can use
counter in my claims principle
right and how does this permission claim
end up in the claims principle well this
is done
by um do you remember the
custom array claims principle factory
that we had created before
so if we go and have a look at this now
i have this additional
uh logic here right this is a
piece of code here in which i'm calling
the weather api
and more specifically i'm calling the my
permissions
endpoint of the weather api and then i'm
just
this will return me an array of strings
which are all the permissions i
have as a user and i will just add a
permission claim
for each one of them to the claims
principle okay
simple as that so let's let's see it in
action
so i do control f5 launch the
application
and
let me close some of these tabs as you
can see
i don't have a the link to
uh call the counter page
or the fetch data page simply because
i'm not
uh i'm not authorized to them i can
obviously
go there by typing your the url and in
that case there's a
routing that prevents me to see seeing
this page but again it's a better user
user experience that i'm not seeing
these links if i'm not authorized to see
them
uh okay then i can login as a let's
login as a
alice first uh right
so i need to do this
here let's login as alice
okay and moment i login as alice
see the counter page link to the counter
page i don't see
the link to the fetch data page because
if i go and have a look at my
permissions
this is the permission i've retrieved
from from the backend
only can use counter right and this is
also added as a this is obviously added
as a claim to my uh my
um principle obviously again i can go
manually to fetch data and in that case
i will see sorry you're not authorized
right so i'm still protected
it's just a better user user experience
from user
i log out and i now log in
again as a bob who's an admin
i now see both links because uh
uh i have both missions and i can go to
fetch data and see
my uh see my weather forecasts
okay because i'm entitled to see them
right
cool um guys i think the time is pretty
much
over and uh um so this is uh
all i had to uh show you uh
for the these uh uh
these subjects um yeah there are some uh
some additional info
on my on my blog so you can go there and
i
leave in a couple of articles there are
more coming soon so follow me on twitter
uh if you want to be notified when uh
when i release these new articles
um yeah just a a big big big thank you
for
having spent this hour together with me
uh and yeah uh this is the github link
where you can
download the demos i will post it on on
slack as well
for your benefits so yeah if you have
any questions
feel free to open your mic and ask
you